In this lesson, I hope to be able to cover aspects of how we can actually now
start looking at neighborhoods of pixels to help us do, among other things, like
smoothing of an image, to be able to extract more information from an image, or
just be able to enhance the image quality.
The two things I want to be able to cover in this lecture is one,
I'm going to talk about how we can smooth an image by using a neighborhood of
pixels on an image.
And also I'm going to specifically talk about an application of this,
which is using median filtering to be able to among other things,
remove errors and smooth out an image.
Median filtering will be another instance of a method where we would be
looking at a neighborhood and running a statistical process on that
neighborhood to create a, a newer rendition of an image.
And again, this will go towards enhancing as how we can do filtering an image at
processing to be able to help us extract content from images.